[Music]
Comcast if you think this 14 seconds of
unnecessary minion just for a fucking
logo is annoying well then you should
immediately drug yourself before
watching the Asheville moving slow
rolling Jesus can't any characters that
are prominently yellow say anything
comprehensible in these movies el macho
is a magical magnet ship that lifts
metallic things off the ground
dramatically one by one instead of all
at the same time like a normal magnet
this guy loves his gun so much that he
refuses to let it go even when he's
being pulled up high enough that certain
death is imminent cool shot and all but
why are metal objects falling I thought
everything was being sucked up into the
magnetic space croissant Arctic Circle
helm scream mother it takes all three
minutes to literally head straight into
the toilet also ha movie but you're
saying this guy went through the magnet
lifting the porta potti up then dropping
it from a terrific height but he just
kept reading the fucking paper in this
version of the universe the Arctic
Circle is located near South Sudan
considering these latitude longitude
numbers
this shows GRU caring for the girls
since he's going all out for Agnes's
party but what's really concerning is
the height of that fucking basketball
goal over the garage how the hell a
three small girls supposed to play on
that book I know this is a ridiculous
animated world and all but what's the
body count for this party on this
attraction alone Gru's house came with a
pre-installed fairy princess police
system also GRU seems like a pretty
large man so why is it that he can be
successfully hoisted by three dr. Mario
pills with goggles
[Music]
since the fairy princess just cancelled
a few minutes ago
this suggests GRU had this entire getup
which fits perfectly at the ready that's
racist a friend natalie is recently
single
Natalie apparently went a little
overboard pre-gaming Agnes's birthday
party if this is what happens when Kyle
takes a leak the entire yard should be a
wasteland
Lucy sounds suspiciously like Miss hatty
from the first movie are we sure that
Miss hatty hasn't assumed a new identity
after having gastric bypass surgery no
one in this entire neighborhood
witnesses this woman beating and running
over a man with a car allowing her to
get away with his kidnapping scot-free
nobody tells me pretty early it's gonna
continue this series assault on
perspective in physics and I'm so
thankful I'm gonna add 10 extra sins for
the remaining bullet of its runtime
minions have witnessed the entirety of
Gru's kidnapping and Trunks stuff edge
but do nothing until she starts to drive
away this little asshole must have
magnets in his back pocket otherwise
there's no reason he should remain
seated on the back of this car
I know Lucy's focused on driving here
but cruise in the trunk so you think she
checked the rearview mirror a couple of
times but no let's let this minion eat
tomfoolery unfold for an interminable
amount of time no one in this bustling
pedestrian area noticed any of that
minion capturing bullsh-- movie
continues the tradition of its main
characters acting in very non discreet
and borderline dangerous ways with
absolutely no consequence why had Lucy
go to the trouble of teasing these
assholes a few seconds ago anyway
they're wide awake but now she doesn't
have any issues with them presumably
because she knows how many toys they're
gonna sell we interrupt this despicable
me movie to bring you Finding Nemo to
find harder we are the anti-villain
league a secret league that is so secret
they didn't even exist in the first
movie even though people were stealing
pyramids shrink rays in the moon but you
want to melt the polar ice caps or even
steal the moon then we noticed which is
why we mostly just sit around with our
thumbs and our assholes because there
are only three or four people in the
world that want to do that agent Wilde
Oh me no obvious Judy Greer character is
inexplicably not voiced by Judy Greer
the lab was devoted to experiments
involving px-41 serum that could only be
tested in the Arctic Circle because of
reasons was this scientist unaware of
what the serum was gonna do to this
bunny or were the other scientists in
the building just sick of it so they
picked him to test this stuff on this
rabbit knowing that the rabbit might
kill it you know how a villain thinks
how a villain
acts and you guys don't I thought you
were the main line of defense against
supervillains have you been doing your
jobs up until this point this submarine
which is only a short boat trip away
from what has to be king Malibu somehow
quietly surfaced during Gru's
conversation even though the entirety of
it was submerged just a few minutes ago
hilarious and all that isn't the whole
point of having minions making them do
menials like rowing all the way back to
fucking dry land she was arranging a
date for you yeah well she's a nut job
and I'm not gone underneath date steve
carell must have thought the voice of
GRU had too much nuance in the last
movie he decided to shout his dialogue
and a sequel also I don't know why it's
so hard for GRU to get a date with his
obvious advantage and a 69 this is why
the jellies and jams
business hasn't taken off these minions
make everything inefficient movie really
knows how to cater to its key
demographic kids today are huge Carmen
Miranda fans fact that I was actively
rooting for this minion to hit the cold
metal of a lab floor tells you exactly
my opinion at these pissed flavored
tater tots just because everybody hates
it doesn't mean it's not good ruse
compelled to lie about the quality of
this jelly for some reason even though
his livelihood hinges on this being a
quality product that sells well even
though there are distinct differences
among the minions up close for this wide
shot the animators just went ctrl-c
ctrl-v a few dozen times so the product
that was not so hilariously made on
accident the last movie is what is now
used to honor its inventor I counted 22
goddamn this movie for habits joke so
far being fart based so grooves letting
fre oh go to join an evil laugh but when
you give up evil yourself do you just
ignore other villains many of which
could affect your newly clean life is
the motto evil and let evil the vacuum
was well past the door before this
little yellow dick was attacked but it's
right in the middle of it here
I guess Nefario took a couple passes on
the rug before leaving also dr. Nefario
literally just left the lab but came
around to the front door and then did
this little ruse to kidnap one of these
little fuckers couldn't have just asked
one of them to go with this given the
unfettered internet access for these
kids I assume this means Agnes is first
exposure to two girls one cup out of all
the ridiculous in this movie the one
thing I'm not believing is a world where
people still go to the mall
it is the cupcake it has to be I got out
of the end then who the hell made all
that stuff and where did they go a much
more interesting backstory would be
about Lucy's blinding hatred of deserts
and how their mere presence induces
white-hot rage boners you got you got a
little bruise covered with icing but
Lucy's hands which did all the baked
good brie or frosting free I guess the
only way this minion romantic fantasy
can end is with full body insertion and
that's dangerous for everyone involved
hard to tell if GRU just automatically
pictures all people in Lucha Libre masks
and just look down identifying el macho
I just I have a lot of Lorex a dual GRU
makes plans to abandon his young
children for the second time in the
first half hour of this movie
what are these assholes celebrating they
haven't done anything and quite a few of
them should be on competent guard of
their formerly evil lair if this is just
some random Tuesday then these little
defective sausage links have a serious
problem Dave Stewart come this way with
me it's not that I don't know these
minions have names like Dave and Kevin
and Sammy and Dick and Francis and all
that it's just that I don't care also
I'm not entirely sure these four names
don't apply to all the minions
and the subtle difference in shape
defines which one is a Kevin and which
one is a Dave this goes on for some time
so I know Lucy initiated this clumsy
break-in but why screw suddenly a
bumbling idiot he's successfully
executed many dangerous heists before
but when he's breaking into a mall
restaurant he turns into Inspector
Clouseau not only are these x-ray
goggles they also changed the color of
things that are potentially of interest
to the wearer of said goggles if this is
what happens when an ice-cream truck
drives by why haven't the minions been
out at long before now oh that's not
good busy man is so busy he's throwing
away a beverage that's still piping hot
well we thought we'd come visit you at
work so we got a cab or stole a car
goddammit why does everyone have
immediate fantasies about this woman of
all the ridiculous things these
characters have done in plain view of
other people this is what gets people to
stop and stare ok these shops look like
they all belong in a shopping mall like
the bridal place right there that
restaurant of course and even the hair
club because this place a speakeasy
casino in the MOL and Edith this
incredibly dry for someone who just
emerged from the water Wow
movie continues to pad its runtime by
accosting mean with this Disney Channel
bull that contributes nothing to the
plot cool make us sound like this sensor
technology was sadly invented the day
after they broke into El macho's
restaurant to find the sear also this
little tidbit is explained to GRU right
before he walks into the store to look
for the serum instead of earlier when he
is given the fancy belt forceable salsa
course he likes me this chicken kick
cruise ass last night and should have no
problem doing it again but only makes
one futile attempt at biting GRU here
I guess it's playing the long con rue
discovered traces of the serum at Eagle
Hair Club interesting no not interesting
it's the breakthrough of your whole
investigation why do we have to have all
this bull about dating and bakery and
minions when we have a fairly
interesting mystery plot that could be
explored I almost want to take us in off
for featuring a MUNGO JERRY song then I
realize this track is featured in almost
every movie beach-themed so Sinnott I
shall also Despicable Me sequel
continues the bartender is Isaac from
Love Boat sight gag even though nobody
in the audience including the kids
parents know who Isaac from Love Boat is
wait so the French maid minion that
Nefario captured earlier is here but why
if he wanted a bunch of the minions from
the get-go he could have taken them then
the ice cream truck stunt was just a
waste of gas and invention him mini
dippin hey where did the heck he's Kevin
this dick doesn't care about many of his
brethren being kidnapped nor is he
interested in telling GRU that almost
all of his work force is out of the
office today is Jillian here in the
first place I thought this was supposed
to be a movie about GRU working for the
good guys to find another bad guy when
it seems to be more about GRU sitting
around his house or his adopted
daughters going to the mall or other
things that make me want it was it group
yeah that's it if I have to watch GRU go
on a date or something I'm turning this
doll goddamnit I'm being
told by the YouTube gods mostly Chris
that I have to continue there's just so
many phonies out there yes I hear you
move you can't decide if it's Mission
Impossible or crazy stupid love but
definitely sucks it being both grew is
not immediately calling Bill Cosby's
attorney right now she's just uh Oh Oh
see this restaurant has massively high
tolerance for people passing out into
their food I guess this really is set in
Los Angeles the straight-up drugging and
torture of this poor lady who was
conceded in polite but certainly not
horrible is played as a casual meet cute
between our actual protagonists of
course this is a kids movie also when
Lucy Ngoc grew unconscious earlier in
the film she put him in the trunk this
woman gets to be tied to the roof for
all the world to see it's definitely
gonna remove us in for this dope for
real track but it also reminds me that
this song lost the Oscar to let it go
that year let it go let it go
I can't dance in my car to that bull for
the egregious Academy error I'll remove
two more sins
you're welcome for us it's empty but we
found traces of the px-41 said a minute
he's our man even though the jar is
empty and the contents are the extremely
dangerous part of the situation we're
going to completely blow our secret
cover and expose it all over the small
floor in front of everyone
what's now well now you're all free to
go back to business
wait GRU didn't get paid finished I know
he's got some decent money but I'd be
shaking this well-funded government
agency down for my efforts also why did
they need grooves help at all they knew
the serum was in the mall somewhere why
do they need a former villain to smoke
it out a regular agent could just go
around and interview the very few
business owners in this small shopping
centre looks like they need you so I
grew romantically you'd start off hating
each other but realize they respect and
even love the other person before some
entity forces them to separate before
proper copulation cliche
20 seconds of GRU returning to old
school grew itch got to play the hit
skits
also I guess Ferrell didn't get a sad
song composed for this montage every
time we've seen this door open it's
opened into the house screws front door
like one of those industrial kitchen
doors that swings both ways
that doesn't seem secure his
flamethrower would be excellent citizens
the fact that actual kids copied this
noise frequently and openly after seeing
this movie earns it five additional
cents and that'll be more if you keep
this up young man minions normally speak
gibberish but also know how to use a
traditional Japanese toast Jesus however
many times grew this passcode up the
hilariously ineffective security system
whips I guess only the penitent man will
pass
maybe this movie's trying to start a
whole character realizes she's in love
via a series of frightening
hallucinations cliche but I'm not buying
it this is cool and all but I'm still
confused over why she karate-chopped all
those cupcakes earlier but where the
hell did that tattoo of the Mexican flag
on his chest go you remember it right
but joke that went on for several
seconds too long earlier in the film not
specific enough so this is your new job
opportunity absolutely and because just
like in the last movie all the world's
villains live within a short drive of
each other in discount LA there should
not be a shock to group he is an
indestructible mindless killing machine
warranties Chris already indestructible
machines
I mean one of them was still alive in
space the last movie Louie has certainly
proved me wrong I thought I was bothered
by the large groups of jaundiced written
dildos the last movie introduced us to
but this are me I've tweaked out grimace
dicks is far worse how the hell did Lucy
know the GRU was going to the Cinco
DeMayo party even if she guessed he'd be
attending wouldn't make more sense to go
back to his house and wait him out there
the last act of this movie is set in
motion due to a silly move by a
supposedly smart redhead so I'll call
this the Lois Lane effect he never
mentioned that you were both working for
the big Lucy who's supposed to be a
highly trained spy allowed her actual
work badge to be stolen by a chicken it
really does sound silly when you say it
out loud
crew takes the motorbike of villany or
whatever the folks call instead of his
normal grew mobile because this
franchise can't be dependent on only
selling minion tours when that did
Elmont you'll find the time to load up
all these new minions into the Rockets
let alone plays the Rockets outside crew
had just left the still raging party and
turned right back around okay let's talk
about El macho's plan he faked his own
death at the height of his popularity
for no reason then hit out by opening a
Mexican restaurant and a fucking mall in
a busy city
I guess biding his time until the serum
was developed in the Arctic Circle and
dr. Nefario is available to be recruited
because Gru's not building anymore and
he just happened to have a bunch of
minions to test the serum on I don't
even know what he wants to do with these
things anyway other than evil evil
indestructible but really how many
fucking things had to go for coming
right for him to enact this incredibly
incoherent plan also did all macho have
to get a loan from the bank to execute
his evil plan or is he just rolling deep
with salsa Y salsa money and if he is
why the hell is he bothering with it
instead of being in El macho's place
where there are many more evil minions
that could use that antidote this Castle
door opens to a ton of wild
uncontrollable evil minion assholes but
none of them leave the area I mean why
are they doing anything el macho wants
Jesus another dr. Nefario ex machina for
the second movie in a row this movie is
the laziest attempt to be ambitious I've
ever seen what's happening pull my
minions where the balls is El macho bin
there's been an uninvited visitor an
evil minion uprising and a fire fight
full of antidote going on for the last
several minutes
I imagine the pitch for this last act
was something like the Green Goblin
Wolverine takes the serum and becomes
grimace who King Kong's for a little bit
then Harry Potter remembered he at the
basilisk
tooth and then the bad guy does it Jim
Carrey impression before he's defeated
also when el macho demonstrated the
power of the serum he showed the Kevin
monster gets shot and burned and eat a
police car all those things seem more
dangerous than a Taser
here we see GRU tased this supposedly
indestructible purple monster el macho
and he reacts just like a normal person
would
well we're done with the villain but
there's ten minutes of runtime left so
we'll definitely get a bunch of singing
minion bolts
also I'm really annoyed that even though
the minions are dressed like Backstreet
Boys they're singing I swear which was
performed by the greatly superior
boyband all for one
wow you think this minion orgy is bad at
the end of the movie what's even worse
is they invited the woman they drugged
tortured and left for dead and she
showed up in case they've been unclear
before I'll say it again these in
post-credit scenes come right in the ear
[Music]
that kid is back on the escalator
Luzi knees on my girls to control the
pitch or volume of my voice when hear
the most annoying sound in the world I
really need you to make a choice on
welcome to Germany on futile they
asshole hasn't straight yeah II agree AC
[Music]
yeah lots of space in this mall
I have been stabbed shot poisoned frozen
home electrocuted and burned there may
be no movie more full of unhealthy
snacking than Despicable Me 2 jams
jellies cupcakes candies and sweets
cookies and even a freaking tortilla
sombrero which I think we all know where
they got that idea
nah yo nut dough man oh man who needs
him some naturebox with the minions and
now the kids he's got a lot of
responsibilities here and he's just
letting all those mouths cram in on
healthy foods what a jerk
if GRU simply went to
naturebox.com/tyler you this first order
that's a reason to get excited and let's
get real for a second we talked a lot
about how healthy nature boxes snacks
are for good reason but let it not be
lost in that discussion that these
snacks also taste amazing
there's like a taste explosion I don't
bruise little runts and minions won't
even realize they're eating healthy they
will be completely fooled you couldn't
fool your mother and the foolish day of
your life if you had an electrified
fulling machine we want you on this
nature box train with us all you have to
do is go to nature box calm
and they ship to your door and they
replace any snacks you don't like and
what exactly are you waiting for get the
date to a computer this should be you a
check box calm